the biden administration being accused
of hypocrisy over its immigration
policies
while republicans argue that the
southern border is wide open
biden's homeland security secretary is
telling migrants fleeing cuba
don't come to america the time is never
right
to attempt migration by sea to those who
risk their lives
doing so this risk is not worth taking
allow me to be clear if you take
to the sea you will not come
to the united states meanwhile the
situation in cuba is getting worse
one protester has reportedly been killed
and more than a hundred have been
detained
and a social media activist was arrested
in her home on live television
greg do migrants seeking
asylum in the u.s do they deserve any
kind of preferential treatment as we
look at what's happening in our border
right now
yeah migrants coming from other places
because i don't think what new york is
going to stop anybody from coming
i think that this is a different
situation than what's happening on our
border because these people are fleeing
totalitarianism
and they're they're risking their lives
going across an ocean
there's no drug cartels involved there's
no people just coming over here for work
and then leaving there aren't like
people coming over here pregnant and
then we allow them and these are people
that are trying to escape
and uh i would be interested in in an
investigation into the root causes
perhaps they could just send kamala
to cuba yeah you think she'll show up
it is it's interesting because what if i
mean you know they're leaving cuba
because of communism but maybe if it was
climate change
actually democrats would treat it a
little bit more differently right
well maybe if she said it was about
climate change they would take it more
seriously yes
yeah but you know what the shameless
psychology mayor
himself is cuban and for him to say
the quote was if you take the c you will
not come to the u.s
the truth what he's saying and what he
has said before
is you will be returned if you get to
the us
so we're going to open the southern
border everybody come on
in for alleged political persecution or
poverty
but when you're a victim of a
totalitarian government or a communist
regime
that is shooting people arresting
journalists or the president of haiti
also was just shot and killed
then we're going to make sure you don't
make it to america because you truly
have a true argument for political
asylum it is an outrage this guy first
of all
i don't believe anything he says he's
been telling us the border is closed
from the day he became the depart the
secretary of homeland security
and this is an outrage to the people of
cuba plus they know if they come from
cuba
they'll probably vote republican so they
got to stop them all from coming in it's
disgusting
actually i think mallorca's parents may
have actually fled cuba
cuba during the revolution i i could be
wrong about that
uh often not wrong but could be so i
await a correction immediately after the
pray
we'll look into it in the commercial
break but i think the white house is
basically saying
if you're going to vote democrat you can
come here illegally but if you're going
to vote republican
don't come because we do know that cuban
americans overwhelmingly vote
republican especially in a swing state
of florida not so swingy recently but
still
and a lot of the first generation
migrants either by birth or asylum or
amnesty
vote democrat and from what i remember
the biden white house has said people in
mexico and the northern triangle
hey it's ellis island down here on the
southern border we're gonna give you a
lawyer we're gonna give you a bed
some cash a bus ticket you know come on
in and we'll help you out
not so with these other people terrible
so
i have an idea uh-oh i've had this idea
before but i've changed my mind
i think we should make cuba the 51st
state
after they're free because you know
eventually communism dies
and here's why you know i have a problem
with making more stars on the flag it
just gives me anxiety about that it's a
nice even number but i do think because
a lot of natural resources in cuba it's
just right off our coast right there
hard-working people great opportunity
for casinos
i think it would make a great 51st state
so when it comes to that let's make it
51 what about
if you do puerto rico you could have i
don't like that trade no no no so but
you're talking about
the trade i'd like to just add one no
but so but you don't have to add one if
you
if we lose a state who do you like to
lose
the council has spoken you've been asked
to leave
dana as you think about that i think
this is this is a serious conversation
serious issue and we're making we're
making
we're serious about it making a little
light up as well but to just agree
no but how do you do you subordinate
some asylum requests over others if
people are scenarios
yeah they're the real ones versus the
fake ones so who determines the
who determines real versus fake i'm just
the judges the judges who were there but
right now what the united states has
done
is they basically said we're going to
assume that everybody from the open
southern border is real
and those people are victims of
shootings they're not i think well
here's the other thing
it's one thing to talk about asylum
rules like these asylum rules
um that we have today were written
specifically for people
like the dissidents we were talking
about in cuba so that they wouldn't be
able to apply seems
very strange but i think that beyond
talking about whether they should come
here it's that what should the biden
administration do to help them there
right they don't want to leave they
would like to improve their their their
um chanting libra todd for liberty and
um
patria evita which is fatherland and
life which is after this um
rap video that they were able to get out
there
rap music i know a lot about rap music i
encourage everyone to look at this video
when you were living with snoop back in
the 90s
yes those are some amazing times and
then i did something in the civil war
dirty bastard you were partying like
crazy but i think that um
on the immigration front it's one it's
one thing that's a dangerous journey
to try to attempt to get to the united
states um a lot of people die that way
and imagine if myarchus had said we care
about you we are going to be there to
help you
we don't want you to attempt that
dangerous journey because it is
dangerous for your life
we are going to try to do and then give
like do something
help them with the internet help them
with something i don't know what all it
could be well i guess
you know the mayor of cuba has an idea
yeah
i don't even know i don't even endorse
that and you might be surprised it's got
to be strange and i'm not
for for hardcore leftists to explain
this
this problem to their kids because if
you're telling your children that
america is the most oppressive
place on earth as people are risking
their life and limb to come here it's a
it's got to be hard to explain that to
kids
i look forward to uh hearing that
explanation i'll tell jesse junior all
about it
a lot more to come on this one hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else